mozzarella is like string cheese right
essentially it should be a little hi my
name is Stanley I'm teddy
I'm Rachel I'm Emily and today we are is
testing mozzarella sticks from various
places we're just trying to figure out
where their home is where did achieve
that so I feel like once you have one
you kind of have them all I don't know
do you like mozzarella sticks okay I
love my chopsticks and I feel like I'm
gonna be good at this so this is the
first one it's yeah it's standard it's
looking good it's looking good
do you want this food you want another
pretty one I'll take the spoon once no I
think this we're doing cuz I'm like a
spooky person okay well here's the thing
presentation is like I guess it kind of
matters at a restaurant but it's a
mozzarella stick we all know it's gonna
explode everywhere that's what happens
sometimes down all right it's pretty
good there's some spillage action going
on on this ones that's always good is it
good it's a good sign this I think is
Buffalo Wild Wings mmm because I feel
like that's Hooters cuz those look
better I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
Hooters off of that Hooters yeah okay I
know I thought that was a good man okay
I'll go with I hop I don't know why I'm
just gonna say it so feel like this is
IHOP
alright moving on okay
these ones I was really excited about
because they look so promising they do
these look like a proper mozzarella
sticks this is how
these are well coated I feel like
they're gonna have a nice crunch yeah
they're like flat though is your [ __ ]
like it's kind of we don't have the
Chiefs Village on this one whole nine
has a little oh there it is a little
action there it is that's how you know
mozzarella is like string cheese right
essentially it should be a little yeah
no no it's feel better the crust makes
me immediately want to think that this
is Buffalo Wild Wings my photos are full
Laver oh it's very hard
yeah the seasoning though it's I think
it's much better I was just holding
myself in because it's not good it's not
like chicken I'm not tricking is it
these were definitely pair well with
chicken wings I'm gonna say buffalo
wings on this one you mean this is a
b-dubs
yeah cuz I could think I taste some of
the chicken with it fry up in the sand
right on the same like that ya know
would they do that
I feel like if there's like a god I
don't like this one I'm gonna be veneers
Buffalo Wild Wings intruders Bo got the
wing look Lawal wings
oh no can I smell the chicken on it I
don't know I could see it I can see it
though
yeah I'll go with that I'm sticking with
Buffalo Wild Wings
this is the third one I think we both
agreed up front these look the worst
they absolutely do you know what it may
be delicious also I'll keep getting the
squeegee ones okay yeah you want oh I'm
still I don't know it looks it looks
okay yeah let's try it it smells like
the seasoning applesauce and I skip this
one this is a straight-up cheese no
crunch whatsoever just oddly I'm just
gonna say this one's Chuckie Cheese yes
because I'm thinking that that might be
IHOP but I also feel like Chuckie Cheese
wouldn't be this good I feel like yeah I
feel like yeah my question is how do
they recycle the cheese sticks
maybe recycle a pizza I don't know if
it's not chuck-e-cheeses
I am gonna write someone a letter sorry
checking cheese I don't love you though
I mean we might be wrong too this is the
last one and these look normal
yeah they look very nice in it there's a
possibility that these could be Chuckie
Cheese
these are nice golden brown I feel like
they're gonna have a nice crunch to it
yeah you can already see the cheese oh
you know you could smell good crunch
going on I can't keep them in front of
my mouth I have to eat them Wow
these are really though yeah I like it
your never go with I hop on I think I
said this was IHOP I'm gonna you got a
swear - John - Bujji won't have yeah
okay okay going back to this one this is
a lot harder than I thought it would be
yeah I think I could say kudos for this
I can see that yeah hmm
yeah I think so
yeah I'm curious now I'll be how we
gonna reveal this is it written on the
bottom of the plate or something no damn
we think these guys are from Buffalo
Wild Wings we do hooters I hop okay
that's not that bad so that okay oh yeah
that makes sense though because they
were like exactly we said chicken
flavors right and those were the best
ones like those are those are pretty
good so number two this is our favorite
one right yeah so were you hop one we
both said B dubs in dubs yeah Buffalo
Wild Wings we thought that they were
hooters but now knowing that the first
ones are hooters were assuming that
these are Buffalo Wild Wings but aren't
answer is hooters yes yeah whoa whoa all
right that's no Chuck E Cheese is it
right dougie T's is it the kids we could
still pull through in the clutch right
now so good all right okay Chuck you
cheese this one is Chuckie Cheese I feel
like this is definitely check your
cheese is it go through I knew it the
kids there they wouldn't care very good
so the last one is your problem over
here that I got all of them right yeah I
don't know the thing which makes sense
for this one too because it's like
pretty regular looking and makes the
like sense for like for it to be a food
chain but these were good these aren't
bad no
is this like one of our skills its life
I god I hope so
hello I'm fine it'll come in handy you
should when you have another taste test
yeah you should see if he's like a
returning champion
[Music]